[Musik]
Beistand vom russisch-orthodoxen
Priester für eine Brücke bei hakif im
russisch besetzten Teil der Ukraine es
ist ein ungewöhnliches Bild aus dem
Krieg und doch sagt es viel über ihn aus
wenig später russische Soldaten auf der
frisch gesegneten Brücke russische
Soldaten auf dem Weg Richtung front
window from Hashtag wir wissen aus der
Geschichte das Krieg ein Test der
Willenskraft und der Logistik ist egal
wie mutig die Soldaten sind sie brauchen
Transportmittel Munition Nahrung Wasser
Medizin das ist essentiell und deshalb
gewinnt häufig die Seite mit der
besseren Logistik
das russische Militär eine der größten
Armeen der Welt Rüstungsausgaben
vergangenes Jahr umgerechnet 66
Milliarden Dollar doch in der Ukraine
geben die russischen Einheiten seit
Monaten ein etwas anderes Bild ab liegen
gebliebene Panzer schlecht versorgte
Soldaten
hat jahrelang die US-Streitkräfte in
Europa angeführt er weiß um die
logistische Strategie und um die
Defizite der russischen Truppen
designt die russischen Versorgungswege
waren nie auf lange bodenoffensiven
außerhalb Russlands ausgelegt
ihre Logistik ist auf einer
unbeschränkte Nutzung der Eisenbahn
angewiesen
und die Ukraine waren sehr clever weil
sie das wussten haben sie vor allem das
logistische Netzwerk der Russen
attackiert
Beispiel die Stadt kopiens zentraler
Knotenpunkt in der Region hackiv hier
verläuft eine Bahnlinie aus Belgorod
einem russischen militärzentrum über
diese Trasse versorgt Russland große
Teile seiner Truppen in der Ostukraine
am 10 September neben Ukrainer die Stadt
kopiensk und den Bahnhof dort
einschneiden so die Versorgung
russischer Truppen in der Umgebung ab
die müssen daraufhin in der gesamten
Region den Rückzug antreten teilweise
wohl fluchtartig in dieser
Versorgungsweg ausfällt dann gibt es
weniger Munition weniger Treibstoff
weniger essen das ist schon ein
signifikantes Problem das hat man ja
auch sofort gemerkt sobald die Ukraine
kubiansk unter Kontrolle bekommen haben
haben die Russen wesentliche Truppen die
bei isum waren zurückgezogen ukrainische
Streitkräfte haben daraufhin leichtes
Spiel stoßen vor nach Issum wo noch kurz
zuvor mehr als 10.000 russische Soldaten
standen
es ist ein Bild das in die vergangenen
Wochen passt jubelnde Ukraine flüchtende
Russen die Material- und Munition
zurücklassen müssen
Sergej goretz betreibt einen
militärblock hat die ukrainische
Regierung beraten für ihn war der
Wendepunkt im Krieg die Lieferung
westlicher Waffen zum Beispiel das
Raketensystem Heimat mit großer
Reichweite und Präzision
nachdem wir dann endlich die Heimat
bekommen haben gab es einen Wandel weil
wir dann angefangen haben die
Schlüsselelemente der Logistik der
russischen Armee zu vernichten also die
lieferpunkte und die Waffenlager das
hatte einen großen Effekt weil die
russische Armee wesentlich weniger
Zugang zu Waffen hatte
die Waffen aus dem Westen auch in
Version im Süden der Ukraine sind sie im
Einsatz Rückblick Verson war die erste
Bezirkshauptstadt die das russische
Militär nach Kriegsbeginn eroberte doch
gern gesehen war es hier nie über Tage
protestierten Bewohner gegen Besatzer
die Kämpfe um die Stadt halten seit
Monaten an es ist vor allem die Lage am
Fürsten japardie herson-strategisch so
wichtig macht
noch kontrollieren russische
truppengebiete westlich des Flusses von
hier wollten sie offensiven ins
Landesinnere starten doch auch in herson
nimmt die Ukraine russische
Versorgungswege ins Visier
19 juli Videoaufnahmen zeigen den
Beschuss der strategisch wichtigen
antonowski Brücke durch die Ukraine die
Brücke für die Russen unbrauchbar
Resultat Ausbesserungsarbeiten
auch die Eisenbahnbrücke antonivsk und
der nova-kochkadam sind nach Beschuss
durch die Ukraine nicht mehr passierbar
die russische Logistik massiv gestört
den Streitkräften bleiben somit nur noch
improvisierte Fähren zur Versorgung der
russisch besetzten Gebiete
so sieht die Antwort Putins auf die
Probleme in der Ukraine aus vergangene
Woche verkündet er die Teilmobilmachung
die Stimmung seither angespannt
haltet den Mund und benehmt euch warum
schreit ihr alle so rum die Spielchen
sind vorbei ihr seid jetzt beim Militär
dort hätte auch eher landen können doch
andere mosaikin ist dem einzugsbescheid
zu vorgekommen vergangene Woche war der
Lokalpolitiker noch in St Petersburg
heute erreichen wir in Usbekistan
in Russland hat die Mobilisierung
angefangen offiziell eine
teilmobilisierung aber die Faktor ist es
eine vollständige Mobilisierung die
keinerlei Einschränkungen hat und ich
will an keinen Kampfhandlungen
teilnehmen die mein Land außerhalb
seiner Grenzen gerade führt niemand hat
uns angegriffen ich verstehe also den
Sinn der Sache nicht ich will nicht
sterben ohne zu wissen wofür
Mui saikin ist nicht der einzige es sind
zehntausende die Putins Rekrutierung
entfliehen an den Grenzen nicht nur zu
Georgien Finnland und Usbekistan
kilometerlange Staus
[Musik]
die Menschen haben Angst niemand will
sterben ich habe sehr viele Nachrichten
bekommen von weit entfernten Bekannten
die nach meinem Rad gefragt haben was
sie denn nun machen sollen mit denen wir
im Übrigen zuvor nie über Politik
gesprochen haben ich weiß also auch
nicht was sie früher so gedacht haben
aber jetzt haben sie Angst
das zeigt sich auch in den russischen
Städten erstmals seit Monaten größere
Proteste gegen den Krieg auch gegen
Putin
gestern hat der Kreml erstmals Fehler
bei der teilmobilisierung eingestanden
Töne die in Russland bislang kaum
vorstellbar waren er Putin hat zum
ersten Mal wirklich offenen Widerstand
und Protest es gibt Berichte und Videos
aus Russlands Regionen aus Pakistan zum
Beispiel wo sehr offene Krieg kritisiert
wird als ein Krieg den Russland
angefangen hat und das bedeutet für
bleibt mir Putin zum ersten Mal ein
wirklicher Test für seine Legitimität
als Präsident unterdessen versucht Putin
in der Ukraine Fakten zu schaffen in
razon in luhans donieck und saporicia
Enden heute die scheinreferenten dieses
Video soll besondere Wahlhelfer zeigen
Wahlhelfer mit Waffen
und während noch gewählt wurde sollen
ukrainische Truppen heute erneut
strategisch wichtige Orte zurückerobert
haben kann Putins time Mobilisierung die
Offensive der Ukraine stoppen
Versorgungsprobleme werden ja eher
größer werden in den nächsten Wochen
insbesondere wenn der Winter kommt also
das ist
sehr brutal und unmenschlich gegenüber
diesen
russischen jungen Männern die jetzt ohne
die nötige Ausstattung ohne die nötige
Ausbildung in diesen Krieg zu schicken
das wird sehr wahrscheinlich zu sehr
hohen Verlusten führen Putin eskaliert
den Krieg sein Einsatz das Leben
hunderttausender Väter Söhne Ehemänner